bonjour à tous place dans un instant à
une audition consacrée à l'AFPA
l'association de formation
professionnelle des adultes c'est le
premier organisme de formation
professionnelle en France en 2012 lAFPA
a appelé l'État à la rescousse
l'association était en crise au cœur de
ses problèmes et bien la trésorerie elle
était au bord de la cessation de
paiement il faut dire qu'elle avait pâti
de la réforme de 2009 qui avait ouvert à
la concurrence la formation
professionnelle des chômeurs jusque-là
lAFPA vivait des subventions de l'État à
partir de cette date et bien elle a dû
répondre à des appels d'offre et donc
être soumise à la concurrence par
ailleurs il y a eu de nombreux problèmes
de gestion tout de suite donc retour à
cette audition qui a eu lieu le 21
janvier au Sénat consacré aux
conclusions de l'enquête que la Cour des
comptes a mené sur laafpa mes chers
collègues si vous le voulez bien nous
allons démarrer les travaux de
notre commission puisque cet après-midi
nous sommes réunis pour pour assister à
la présentation donc de l'enquête
réalisée par la Cour des comptes à la
demande du Sénat sur l'association pour
la Formation Professionnelle des Adultes
la pasa cette enquête résulte d'une
saisine commune de la commission des
Affaires sociales et de la commission
des finances nos deux collègues
rapporteurs devaient nous rejoindre des
finances mais ils vont peut-être se
joindre à nous dans un instant nous
avons le rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales col Janer qui est
présent ce qui ma fois pour la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales est le plus
important l'enquête donc a été confié à
la 5e chambre de la Cour des comptes et
va nous être présenté par sa présidente
Madame Anne from Meuris que je remercie
de sa présence elle est accompagnée de
Monsieur Pascal
Duchadeuil de Monsieur Michel Davi de
Virville pardon et de Madame Sylvie
espard tous les trois conseillers
maîtres à la Cour des
comptes il m'a semblé utile pour
compléter cette présentation de convier
également à cette audition les
représentants de l'AFPA et ceux de la
Délégation générale à l'emploi et à la
formation prof professionnelle cette
dernière n'est pas la seule
administration impliquée dans les
différentes problématiques abordées par
l'enquête mais elle est sans doute la
plus en prise avec l'émission confiée à
l'AFPA monsieur Yve Barou président de
l'AFPA devait être parmi nous mais se
trouve dans l'impossibilité d'être
présent je lui souhaite de bien se
rétablir l'AFPA est donc représenté par
Monsieur Hervé estamp directeur général
la dgfp et quant à elle représenté par
Monsieur Christophe strassel adjoint à
la déléguée générale et Monsieur
Jean-Marc
Huard ah non pardon et j'ai une dame
excusez-moi madame je madame di
excusez-moi vraiment sous du coup vous
êtes chef de la mission voilà j'avais
Monsieur Jean-Marc Huard sous-directeur
des politique de formation et du
contrôle mais visiblement il n'est pas
parmi nous je voudrais rappeler qu'il y
a un peu plus d'un an et demi l'annonce
de grav difficultés financières et la
démission du président de l'AFPA ont été
le point d'org d'une situation
particulièrement préoccupante que nous
sommes ici nombreuses et nombreux à
avoir déplorer depuis quelques années
déjà le 10 octobre
2012 le nouveau président de l'AFPA donc
monsieur yvbarou était venu devant notre
commission présenter un premier
diagnostic et esquisser les axes d'un un
plan de refondation tel qu'il nous
l'avait indiqué destiné avec le soutien
de l'État à replacer l'association sur
une trajectoire viable et à préserver
les compétences et les savoir-faire
qu'elle met de longues dates au service
de la formation professionnelle j'ai
souhaité que la Cour des comptes puisse
nous éclairer sur les raisons qui ont
conduit à cette situation j'ai le
sentiment que l'AFPA a été déstabilisé
par la réforme qui lui a été imposée en
2009 et dans laquelle elle a dû
s'engager sans y être véritablement
préparée à cela peut-être mais la Cour
des comptes nous en dira sans doute un
peu plus s'ajoutent des mesures de
gestion qui n'étaient pas complètement
opportunes il est
intéressant pour notre commission que
cette enquête soit publiée à ce moment
même alors que va très prochainement
commencer l'examin du projet de loi sur
la formation professionnelle celui-ci
devrait d'ailleurs comporter une
disposition relative aux emprises
immobilières utilisées par l'AFPA je
vais sans plus attendre passer la parole
à Madame froment Meuris pour la
présentation de l'enquête je demanderai
ensuite à
messsieur estampe et et strassel et non
du coup monsieur strassel donc de
brièvement faire part de leurs
observations nous ouvrirons ensuite le
débat avec les sénateurs je précise que
notre audition est ouverte à la presse
et fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo en
vue de sa diffusion sur le site internet
du Sénat et je signale du coup l'arrivée
du rapporteur monsieur patria que j'ai
annoncé il y a un instant et qui nous
rejoint je vous laisse la
parole merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente je suis donc entourée vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure par le
rapporteur Sylvie espard et le
contre-rapporteur de cette enquête qui
est Michel David Virville et par le
président de la section qui est
compétente dans les domaines de la
formation professionnelle alors cette
enquête sur la FA elle s'est déroulée au
premier semestre 2013 vous l'avez
rappelé à la demande des deux présidents
des commissions des affaires sociales et
des commissions des finances du Sénat et
elle est intervenue dans une période de
grand bouleversement pour l'association
puisque à la suite de la nette
détérioration de la situation financière
de lAFPA en 2012 cela entraîné la
démission de son président et de son
directeur général un nouveau président a
été nommé en juin 2012 un nouveau
directeur général il est ici est arrivé
en janvier 2013 et les équipes de
direction ont été profondément
renouvelées que ce soit au niveau
national ou au niveau régional donc
pendant que la cour au fond faisait son
son enquête à son arrivée le président
de l'AFA a élaboré un plan de
refondation pour la période
2013-27 dans un triple objectif
transformer le modèle pédagogique
développer l'activité de l'association
et puis et puis redresser la situation
financière parallèlement l'association a
sollicité l'expertise du comité
interministériel de restructuration
industrielle qui assure la conciliation
entre les acteurs publics et les acteurs
privés afin d'intervenir auprès des
banques et auprès de la Caisse des
Dépôts le champ des investigations de la
Cour a été arrêté lors d'échange avec la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat et bien sûr en tenant compte de ce
contexte très particulier que je viens
de rappeler quatre axes d'analyse ont
été
retenus l'organisation et la gouvernance
de l'AFPA l'action de l'AFPA pour former
les demandeurs d'emploi et cette analyse
elle a été conduite plus
particulièrement dans trois régions
champagnearden provencealpe côteazur et
rôalpe ensuite la gestion et la
situation financière de l'association et
enfin la problématique immobilière je
vais revenir très brièvement sur chacun
de ces quatre axes d'analyse pour vous
présenter les principaux at de la cour
sur l'organisation et la gouvernance de
l'AFPA depuis 2009 l'association a perdu
son statut d'opérateur de l'État et au
fond elle doit se positionner comme un
acteur parmi d'autres sur le marché de
la formation professionnelle dont elle
représente un peu plus de 5 % du chiffre
d'affaires total en dépit de cette
évolution les statuts et la gouvernance
de l'association rest reste marqué par
une présence forte de l'État dont la
stratégie vis-à-vis de
l'AFPA nous a paru devoir être clarifié
parallèlement l'AFPA qui est désormais
soumise au droits de la concurrence et
qui doit adapter son organisation et son
offre de formation à ses nouveaux
clients et en particulier aux exigences
des conseils régionaux à tardé à se
conformer à s'adapter au nouveaux cadres
concurrentiels qui s'imposait à elle le
plan d'entreprise 2004-29 n'a pas
atteint ses objectifs de réduction des
effectifs le plan de départ volontaire
et de mobilité géographique n'ayant pas
pu être mené à son terme dans un climat
social particulièrement difficile quant
au plan stratégique qui a suivi qui
était prévu pour
2010-214 il reposait sur des choix de de
gestion et d'organisation qui se sont
révélé assez rapidement inadapté et il a
dû être interrompu en 2012 en
particulier la stratégie de laafpa a
tardé à intégrer le rôle des régions
dans la formation professionnelle et
surtout aussi son organisation
territoriale n'a pas suffisamment évolué
au final entre 2007 et 2012 l'AFPA a
perdu près de 24 % de ces stagiaires et
plus du tiers de ces stagiaires
demandeurs d'emploi qui constituaient
pourtant son public
prioritaire le plan de refondation
adopté en 2012 constitue ainsi une
dernière chance pour l'organisme il
renforce le positionnement de
l'ingénierie au plan national comme au
plan régional pour qu'elle irrigue
l'ensemble du réseau et il abandonne les
structures
interrégional et les campus qui avaient
été initiés par le plan précédent pour
revenir à une organisation régionale
renforcé et mieux à même de répondre sur
le terrain aux demandes des
collectivités et de Pôle
Emploi les constats principaux sur la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi lAFPA
se définit traditionnellement comme
l'opérateur de référence de la formation
des demandeurs d'emploi et de fait
l'association se révèle relativement
performante dans ce domaine puisque plus
de la moitié des stagiaire demandeur
d'emploi ayant obtenu un titre
professionnel sont 6 mois après la fin
de leur formation en situation
d'emploi cependant forcé de constater
que la place de Lapa sur le marché de la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi n'est
pas à la hauteur de ces possibilités
puisqu'elle n'obtient que 22 % des
financements disponibles pour former les
demandeurs d'emploi cette faible
compétitivité s'explique notamment par
l'adaptation tardive de l'offre de l'fp
à la commande publique régionale je l'ai
déjà mentionné et qui est notamment
illustré par l'absence systématique
d'analyse de marché il y a aussi des
critiques qui sont formulées
par les stagiaires et par les financeurs
sur le déroulement des formations
dispensées et qui pèse sur le
positionnement de l'AFPA elles mettent
notamment en évidence
l'indisponibilité des matériels
pédagogique et l'absence fréquente des
des formateurs qui peut
résulter de l'organisation actuelle des
stages qui est très fragilisée par le
fait que il y a un formateur unique par
par
formation sur la gestion et la situation
financière de l'association la
conjugaison des difficultés d'adaptation
de l'AFPA et de ces erreurs stratégique
successive a eu une incidence directe
sur sa situation financière
l'association a enregistrer une perte de
près de 92 millions d'euros en 2012 qui
représente près de 10 % de son chiffre
d'affaires et elle a dû bénéficier d'une
aide de l'État sous forme d'obligations
associatives de 110 millions d'euros qui
ont été
versé en juin
2013 aujourd'hui la situation économique
et financière de laafpa reste très
fragile le plan de
refondation se fonde sur des hypothèses
très ambitieuses tant pour le
financement attendu des organismes
institutionnels et paritaires que pour
les formations qui sont
commandé et les prévisions de résultats
établies au 30 octobre 2013 c'est-à-dire
un peu avant que nous remettions notre
rapport au Sénat ces prévisions
montraient que les objectifs fixés pour
2013 ne seraient probablement pas
atteint et qu'une perte probable
d'environ 38 millions d'euros devait
être
envisagé la Cour a mis en exerg dans
cette partie sur la gestion et la
situation financière de l'AFPA des voies
d'amélioration interne des progrès
qui existe qui demeure en complément du
soutien des pouvoirs publics et des
banques et aussi dans la ligne des
efforts que fait elle-même l'association
ces voies d'amélioration elles
concernent la réduction des effectifs du
siège elles concern la révision des
rémunérations et des avantages qui sont
liés elle concerne aussi le renforcement
de la mobilité des personnel en
particulier des formateurs et là c'est
un constat qui est tout de même très
singulier parce qu'il faut savoir que
les formateurs à l'association ne
représentent que moins de la moitié des
des effectifs et puis également les
retards de facturation et l'absence de
gestion des stocks appelle des mesures
correctrices enfin sur le dernier axe
d'analyse de la cour les implantations
immobilières laafpa occupe en grande
partie un patrimoine de l'État qui a été
mis à sa disposition de très longue date
dans le cadre de beau avantageux qui
n'ont jamais été révisés
ce patrimoine n'est pas convenablement
répertorié et il est souvent mal
entretenu son transfert à l'association
avait été décidé par la loi d'août 2009
sur la formation professionnelle mais il
a été remis en question à la suite d'une
censure du Conseil constitutionnel qui a
considéré qu'il s'agit de BI publics
protégés même si ce que nous avons
constaté l'intégralité de ce patrimoine
immobilier dont l'association assure la
gestion est constaté à l'actif de son
bilan alors de très nombreux avis ont
été rendus au sujet de la dévolution des
biens de l'État et il convergeent tous
vers la solution de beau amphitthéotiqu
administratifs dont les modalités de
mise en œuvre cependant sont apparus à
la cour comme très flous et faisant
l'objet au moment où nous terminions
notre rapport de désaccord entre
l'association et France domain et ces
incertitudes entraînent des conséquences
très défavorables sur la gestion de
l'AFPA puisque et sur son financement
puisque ces beau sont prévus comme étant
des garanties bancaires du plan de
refondation et que l'expérimentation
d'un partenariat avec la société Adoma
pour l'hébergement des stagiaires repose
lui aussi sur la signature de ces Bau
concernant les implantations de l'AFPA
la rationalisation reste complètement
inachevée qu'il
s'agisse de la
rationalisation sur les territoires ou
bien sur le siège concernant le siège et
les centres de formation en î de France
alors face à ce bilan critique et au
constat d'une situation financière
fragile la Cour dans son rapport formule
12 recommandations qui porte sur
l'ensemble des champs d'analyse que je
viens de brièvement résumé et que l'on
peut regrouper au fond sous trois
orientations prioritaires pour pour la
cour elle appelle d'abord l'état à
clarifier sa stratégie vis-à-vis de
l'AFPA dont la situation est
actuellement très ambigue puisque les
garanties financières que l'État lui
apporte pour soutenir sa négociation
avec les établissements bancaires
implique en effet un
interventionnisme plus important dans la
gestion de l'association qui est
pourtant désormais je l'ai rappelé tout
à l'heure un organisme de formation
banalisé soumis aux règles de la
concurrence la Cour préconise par
ailleurs d'adapter l'organisation des
stages qui est fragilisé je l'ai
signalé fragilisé aujourd'hui par le
fait qu'il y a un formateur unique par
formation elle préconise également de
systématiser la production d'analyse de
marché national et régional et enfin et
surtout aussi elle insiste sur la
poursuite du processus de négociation
sur le maillage territorial sans que la
contrainte d'aménagement du territoire
prévale ce qui a été longtemps le cas
sans que cette contrainte prévale sur la
rationalisation absolument indispensable
du patrimoine immobilier de l'AFPA voilà
madame la Présidente très brièvement
résumer les constats de la cour et bien
sûr mes mes collègues et moi-même nous
tenons à la disposition de la commission
pour répondre à vos
questions je vous remercie madame la
Présidente je vais peut-être donner la
parole à Monsieur estamp et puis ensuite
évidemment
j'ouvrirai à Monsieur strassel ensuite
et à Monsieur strassel également oui la
dgfp monsieur
estampe madame la Présidente
merci mesdames et messieurs ce contrôle
de la Cour des comptes effectivement a
débouché sur le rapport qui vient d'être
commenté par madame la Présidente Moris
nous n'avons pas bien évidemment de de
de réserve ni de contradiction à ce
stade étant donné que la procédure a
permis de de pouvoir au contradictoire
euh communiquer nos observations et en
plus nous avons pr de nous faire
entendre donc ce qui veut dire que nous
n'avons bien entendu pas de complément à
apporter
euh je me permet de revenir sur la
problématique de Lapa aujourd'hui la
réalité de sa situation car ce sont
peut-être des éléments d'actualité qui
pourraient vous être utiles dans dans la
bonne compréhension de la situation du
moment
comme la rappelé madame la Présidente
j'ai été nommé il y a 1 an donc le 2
janvier donc les priorités court terme
étai un de d'assurer le le le le
financement du plan de refondation donc
l'état il a pris une grande part dès le
début janvier mais pas uniquement étant
donné que il ne couvre environ que la
moitié du financement il a fallu après
avoir des intervention de de banquers
privés la BNP Société Générale pour
qu'il complète ce tour de table
le la deuxème priorité était de
d'apaiser le climat
social laafpa était dans un état social
de dialogue social particulièrement
délabré et où donc il a fallu renouer
les fils du dialogue social et
remobiliser l'entreprise car c'est une
entreprise même si l' statut associatif
c'est un ensemble d'hommes et de femmes
tendu vers un objectif commun c'est une
entreprise donc il a fallu les
remobiliser la troisème priorité a été
de de rénover notre offre off qui est
une offre qui était assez
datée assez relativement calée sur les
titres professionnels du ministère ce
qui n'est pas une un défaut en tant que
tel mais qui est relativement peu souple
et trop longue pour pouvoir répondre à
d'autres besoins notamment ceux manant
des
entreprise comme il a été rappelé une
autre priorité était l'immobilier
j'aurai l'occasion d'y revenir parce que
ces sujets sont encore pendant et
surtout il a fallu réorganiser
l'entreprise il faut faut bien
comprendre que lAFPA a toujours vécu
sous subvention et donc ne serait-ce que
l'acte de facturer recouvrer des
créances tout ça sont des processus qui
ne sont inconnus de l'entreprise
commercialiser répondre aux appels
d'offres une démarche marketing ça sont
des mots qui n'ont jamais existé dans le
vocabulaire afpayen et que l'on a
découvert progressivement ces dernières
années mais avec la pratique des
débutants vous vous en doutez
bien à la fin de 2013 la situation est
la suivante donc nous avions un budget à
7 4 millions nous ne serons pas au
budget nous l'avions identifié
relativement rapidement nous il va nous
manquer un peu plus de 30 millions on va
être aux alentours de 755 millions donc
c'est c'est tout à fait conforme avec
les prévisions de la
cour cela étant si nous avons pas
atteint ce chi d'affaair c'est pour un
certain nombre de raison extrêmement
précise c'est
que sur des financements étatiques
notamment via des appels d'OF de la
directe il y a eu des retards donc ça
nous a privé d'un certain de de
recettes sur d'autres programmes qui
étaient prévus qui étaient budgetés ces
progames n'ont pas eu nont pas eu lieu
donc nous avons effectivement pâti et
nous avons identifié en en tout début
d'année vers le mois de février mars
mars avril que l'année risquait d'être
complexe et donc nous l'avions assez
rapidement fait remonter cette
information donc Infiné nous sommes la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes euh
nous n'avons paradoxalement pas besoin
de financement complémentaire par
rapport au plan de financement qui a été
identifié avec les banques et avec
l'État étant donné que dans le plan de
refondation il y a un volume
d'investissement assez important donc ce
qui nous manque en chaffire on a il nous
en manque un petit peu moins un
excellent bout d'exploitation parce
qu'on a fait des économies et pour le
reste on a réduit notre volume
d'investissement en 2013 ce qui veut
dire qu'en terme de sortie de cash on a
pu garder des trésoreries positives donc
pendant toute l'année nous avons une
trésorerie excédentaire et qui a été
au-dessus des prévisions faites par le
cabilet Mazar qui nous audite au nom du
du Siri donc donc ce qui veut dire que
il n'y a plus aucune tension de va-t-on
finir vat-on payer les salaires à la fin
du mois donc nous avons vécu quand même
cette année-là de manière plus
confortable grâce aux dotations nous
avons reçu et à la gestion prudante que
nous avons
déployé néanmoins néanmoins euh l'année
n'est pas satisfaisante ça éé une année
de restructuration très forte qui étit
consacrée à effectivement restructurer
l'entreprise donc on a dit déployer les
processus adapté réduire nos effectifs
euh nous avons en année 2013 fait - 360
ETP donc équivalent de temps plein euh
ce qui est
significatif nous avons baisser notre
point mort en terme de frais de
fonctionnement et effectif de près de 30
millions ce qui là aussi est
relativement significatif le tout en
plan social et le tout en gardant un
haut niveau de dialogue social nos
élections des des syndicats ont eu lieu
au mois de décembre et 85 % de Tau de
participation donc très grande
participation et ce sont les deux
syndicats qui avaient signé le plan de
refondation qui ont été qui sont sortis
renforcés des élection ce qui montre
bien que la voix du dialogue social qui
a été développée par le président Barou
et a été bien reçu par l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux et que donc nous
sommes dans une situation de ce point de
vue-là extrêmement
constructive la perspective 2014 euh
nous avons fait notre budget ce budget a
été fait à une époque où nous n'avions
pas encore de de certitude sur le plan
100000 alors je sais pas si tout le
monde est bien au fait de ce sujet-là
une formation prioritaire en faveur de
l'emploi qui qui devait être un plan
70000 mais finalement va être un plan
100000 euh ce qui veut dire que notre
budget euh nous nous l'estimion un peu
prudentiel donc il a été audité par le
cabinet Mazard qui a validé l'ensemble
des hypothèses et donc ce budget 2014
prévoit un retour un excédent bruit
d'exploitation légèrement positif donc
nous devrions être plus 2 ou 3 millions
alors que cette année nous allons être à
- 35 en terme d'excè en brille
d'exploitation ce qui veut dire que on
on est en train de vraiment d'aller dans
le bon sens et le cabinet Mazard a noté
une inflexion au mois de juillet
c'est-à-dire que les 6 premiers mois ont
été continuement enfin une baisse
continue étant donné que 2012 av une
année relativement catastrophique d'un
point de vue de la mobilisation et de la
production donc les six premiers Mo on
étent difficiles mais depuis le mois de
juillet euh nos stagiaires ont regagné
les centres de formation euh nous sommes
ordre de bataille notre organisation
fonctionne nous arrivons à à sourcer les
stagiaires parce que ce qu'il faut voir
c'est qu'ell lavent pas c'est très c'est
un métier très difficile parce que nous
devons avoir des financements ce qui
veut dire des appels d'offresis par les
régions parort l'emploi donc il faut
être compétitif et ensuite une fois que
nous avons ces financement il faut
trouver les stagiaires donc il y a toute
une organisation pour dire au stagiaires
il faut venir à lavep euh donc nous nous
sommes réorganisé différemment nous
avons fait les efforts qu'il fallait les
investissements qu'il fallait euh le
site afpa.fr c'était 1,2 million de
visiteurs au mois de mars aujourd'hui
c'est 3,5 million de visiteurs par mois
donc ce qui veut dire que en terme de de
sourcing comme on dit chez nous on a on
a quand même bien progressé donc le
budget 2014 sera le un budget après une
année de restructuration en budget de
progressif retour à des fondamentaux et
une certaine équilibre
financier nous avons également déployé
notre nouvelle offre pédagogique nous
avons travaillé pendant un an sur la
nouvelle offre pédagogique donc donc une
offre plus modulaire alors la
modularisation n'est pas une fait en soi
mais la modularisation permet de
découper la formation et de pouvoir
raisonner sur ce qu'on appelle des
champs de métier c'est-à-dire d'avoir
plus des modules communs à plusieurs
formations ce qui permet de répondre à
une des critiques fondées d'ailleurs de
la cour qui de dire qu'il y a un
formateur par formation ce qui la
rigidifie dès lors qu'on est sur un
champ de métier on peut grâce à la
modularisation pouvoir dire il y a un
formateur plaquiste qui va faire un
module avec les plombiers et avec les
carleurs et avec les peintres avec ça on
peut arriver à mieux gérer nos effectifs
donc avoir moins recours les effectifs
et surtout offrir plus de souplesse donc
cette offre là ce travail là a été fait
en 2013 et il sera présenté
officiellement au mois de mars le 18
mars la date est déjà prévue
2014 nous avons deux autres sujets
stratégiques enfin trois autres sujets
stratégiques le premier c'est
sur alors il ne s'agit pas bien entendu
contester la la régionalisation nous
estimons que c'est au plus près du
terrain qu'on peut voir les meilleures
choses mais cela laisse un angle mort
sur ce qu'on appelle les formations à
rayonnement national c'est-à-dire qu'il
y a un certain nombre de formations dont
on voit bien qu'elle nécessite de lourds
investissements pour accompagner le
développement des énergies marines
renouvelaable ou la fibre optique ou que
sais-je où il est nécessaire d'avoir des
dispositifs qui ne soient pas uniquement
à Visé régional donc c'est en ce sens
que et c'est pareil pour des des gros
centres de BTP qui où on en a un
Limousin ce n'est pas fait pour la
région Limousin c'est fait pour la
France donc si vous avez si vous envie
de vous former dans l'aéronautique
intuitivement vous sentez qu'il va
falloir se déplacer à Toulouse pour
faire votre formation donc il y a un
certain nombre de de formations dont on
estime qu'aujourd'hui elles sont en
train de mourir à cause d'une
insuffisance de commande publique de la
part des régions principalement qui sont
bien entendu conscients de ces de ces
problématiques là mais doivent arbitrer
entre différentes priorités donc nous
avons là un vrai sujet sur lequel nous
essayons de
sensibiliser le législateur et et toutes
les les personnes que nous pouvons sur
le fait qu'il faut vraiment identifier
les moyens de se de financer ces offres
à finalité nationale ce qui ne remet pas
du tout en cause la régionalisation
j'étais récemment à Cherbourg la semaine
dernière pour inaugurer notre centre
national énergie EMR énergie marine
renouvelable avec la région avec le
président du conseil régional avec le
préfet de région et on voit bien le la
combinaison vertueuse qui peut se
produire en travers ces deux ces deux
dimensions la deuxième problématique
c'est que l'pa est structurellement sur
un marché des demandeurs d'emploi qui
est un marché où il va y avoir désormais
un seul acheteur c'est les régions avec
potentiellement un transfert des
crédites pour l'emploi vers les région
et donc nous avons dans chaque région un
acheteur et 58000 organismes de
formation donc vous comprenez que la
situation concurrentielle qui est la
nottre n'est pas favorable du tout et un
organisme comme
lAFPA dans une course au prix et dans
une lostisation des formations a perdu
donc pour nous notre enjeu c'est
d'arriver à segmenter le marché de
manière à expliquer à nos financeurs que
nous ne vendons pas de la formation mais
nous ce que nous proposons c'est un
retour à l'emploi donc avec un
accompagnement avec de l'hébergement
avec de la restauration et avec une
qualification tout ça qui qui permet le
retour à l'emploi de manière plus
certaine c'est ce que dit la cour dans
son rapport euh les personnes qui sont
passées par par laafpa ont 68 % de
chance d'avoir un emploi 6 mois après
alors que le demandeur d'emploi de base
c'est 54 %. donc on est là au nœud du
problème parce que comme le dit souvent
mon Président OL Barou autant une
compagnie aérienne lowcost vous mène de
la destination a à la destination B mais
une formation lowcost qui ne vous
qualifie pas et qui nous apprend rien
vous metne nulle part donc le low cost
n'a pas lieu d'être dans le le monde
dans lequel nous sommes de la formation
donc nous nous plaidons pour ça et nous
essayons d'avoir une démarche
qualitative sachant que les conseils
régionaux de plus en plus refuse de
payer tout ce qui est autour de la
formation c'est-à-dire qu'on a deux
trois Conseils régionaux qui maintenant
ne veent plus payer l'hébergement ou la
restauration des stagiaires soit finance
les stagiaires directement soit disent
non c'est pas c'est pas utile et donc ce
qui veut dire que c'est pour nous lave
pas un vrai défi enfin notre dernier
sujet stratégique c'est notre immobilier
commment on l'a dit euh nous avons alors
les BEA ont deux finalités les
bonsittiqu administrativ dont tu parlé
la présidente ont deux finalités la
première c'est d'offrir des garantie
pour mobiliser du crédit moyen terme
c'estàdire pour investir la deuxième
c'est que ça nous ouvre les portes d'une
autonomie de gestion et donc la
possibilité de nouer des partenariats on
a cité Adoma mais on peut citer les
offices publicqus HLM le cru ou que
sais-je de manière à confi de manière
partenariale à des gens qui ne sont pas
détenus par des fonds de pensions
américains voyez comme lava qui à peu
près les mêmes finalités d'utilité
sociale de se dire on va essayer de
mettre en commun un certain nombre de
moyens et de pouvoir dire bah tiens on
va prendre lafpap faire un contrat avec
Adoma on va leur sé des droits réels sur
une partie de notre BAA ils vont
construire il y aura du public à domain
il y aura du public àpa ça permet une
meilleure mutualisation des moyens une
meilleure économie des donniers
publicqus au niveau national et ça
permet surtout à lAFPA de rénover son
hébergement alors qu'aujourd'hui Lapa
n'est pas en capacité financière de de
de vraiment rénover et 134 sites où il y
a de l'hébergement donc c'est un un parc
assez
considérable malheureusement la
problématique des BEA est extrêmement
complexe et que pour vous donner la
dernière actualité nous avions nos deux
premiers BEA signés les BEA al y a un
certain nombre de clauses qu'il faut
négocier parce que nous pensons que nous
lafp nous avons souhaité ne pas porter
un certain nombre de travaux
l'accessibilité handicapé parce que non
pas nous contestons le bien fondé de
cette mesure mais c des sommes
considérabl et nous ne sommes pas en
capacité de pour les financer et donc
une négociation a eu lieu on avait
trouvé un point d'équilibre mais comme
la signature des BAA se fait au niveau
départemental au niveau des concentrés
on a un BEA qui est arrivé au bout qui a
été signé un autre qui n'a pas pu être
signé parce que directeur départemental
des finances publiques estimé qu'il
fallait faire un certain nombre de
modification donc nous sommes en train
de réfléchir sous l'égide de la dgfp qui
nous a convi une réunion récemment pour
trouver des processus qui soi plus
carossable passerexpression sachant que
nous espérons que dans la loi il y ait
une disposition qui nous pour nous
serait particulièrement intéressante qui
ne coûte rien à personne ce serait le
déclassement si des biens étaient passés
en BE à lapac c'est bien rentrent dans
le domaine privé de l'État et non plus
le domaine public pour des raisons un
peu techniques mais aujourd'hui si on
apporte en garantie au banquiers des BA
en domaine public on est obligé
d'investir sur le site en question alors
que si c'est un B en domaine privé nous
Pons IR sur l'ensemble des sites AFPA
donc en terme d'efficience nos
investissements pour nous ce
déclassement là serait extrêmement
fondamental voilà madame la
Présidente très bien merci Monsieur
strassel si vous voulez bien prendre la
suite merci madame la Présidente alors
pour ce qui concerne la position de la
Délégation générale à l'emploi et à la
formation professionnelle que je
représente
ici quelques points relativement bref
tout d'abord je voulais marquer l'accord
sur l'ensemble du diagnostic porté par
la Cour des comptes dans la mesure où
comme lAFPA l'a indiqué tout à l'heure
la procédure contradictoire a été riche
et ouverte et où la dgfp a pu faire
valoir un certain nombre de ces de ces
arguments donc le rapport qui résulte de
cette
procédure recueille de notre côté un un
plein accord à la fois sur sur le
diagnostic et puis sur la plupart des
pistes et des orientations qui sont
suggérées euh quelques
éléments peut-être pour
situer la position de l'État par rapport
à l'fpa aujourd'hui vous savez que lAFPA
a été pendant longtemps un opérateur de
l'État que c'est un opérateur historique
puisque l'fpa a été créé en 1949 mais
que les évolutions réglementaires et
législatives ont fait que la position de
l'État par rapport à l'fpa a
considérablement varié et évolué au
cours des dernières années alors trois
points peut-être quelques points de
rappel de contexte sur les grandes
évolutions qui sont intervenues qui ont
effectivement comme cela a été rappelé
quelques peu déstabiliser l'AFPA un
deuxième point sur ce que l'État
aujourd'hui attend de l'AFPA et en quoi
l'fpa qui est l'un des acteurs du
service public de l'emploi participe à
la mise en œuvre de la politique de
l'emploi du gouvernement et puis troème
point sur ce que l'État fait aujourd'hui
pour soutenir le plan de refondation de
l'AFA alors les éléments de contexte qui
sont très connus je vais aller très vite
l'élément de contexte principal c'est
bien entendu la régionalisation de la
formation professionnelle qui a mise en
difficulté l'AFPA dans la mesure où
l'AFPA a était un opérateur lié
historiquement à l'état et que du coup
s'align sur un nouveau
commanditaire n'a pas été facile pour
pour l'association l'une des
conséquences de cette évolution ça a été
le passage d'un régime de financement
fondé sur des subventions publiques un
régime de euh marché hein qui a
nécessité une transformation des
procédures de lAFPA et puis aussi de son
offre et de l'adaptation de cette offre
au marché cette adaptation est en cours
comme cela a été expliqué à la fois par
la cour et par Monsieur estamp du chemin
reste à parcourir mais un certain nombre
d'évolutions positives sont d'ors et
déjà
intervenu par ailleurs lAFPA a perdu au
cours des dernières années un certain
nombre des compétences qu'elle avait
historiquement exercé je pense en
particulier à l'action en matière
d'orientation des demandeurs d'emploi
puisque les personnes qui exerçaient
cette fonction à l'AFPA les psychologues
de l'AFPA ont été versé dans le
personnel de Pol emploi lAFPA ayant
perdu cette cette compétence en matière
d'orientation par ailleurs un certain
nombre d'évolution de la politique des
partenaires ou des commanditaires de
l'AFPA est intervenu je pense en
particulier à la formation des
travailleurs handicapés ou l' pas
enregistré une basse
significative de son chiffre d'affaires
lié à une diminution de la commande en
matière de formation des travailleurs
handicapés et puis enfin il y a un
élément plus qualitatif qui est le fait
que le passage à une logique de marché
public c'est accompagné d'une assez
grande diversité des procédures et puis
également des exigences des différentes
régions dans le régime de la commande
publique ce qui fait que l'AFPA n'a pas
pu mettre en œuvre une stratégie unique
sur l'ensemble du territoire alors même
que l'AFPA demeure un organisme assez
centralisé mais doit s'adapter à des
commandes régionales assez différentes
les unes des autres et ça c'est un
élément je pense de difficultés dans
l'adaptation de laavpa à ce nouveau
contexte alors le contexte est embrossé
quels sont les attentes aujourd'hui de
l'État vis-à-vis de cet opérateur qui
est lAFPA bien pour essayer de cerner ce
que peut attendre l'avpa de de l'état de
l'avpa faut voir ce que sont aujourd'hui
à notre sens les atouts de cet organisme
de formation il a un atout historique
hein qui est la compétence de l'AFPA en
matière de titre professionnel ça a été
rappelé tout à l'heure ça reste un
élément très important de l'offre de
l'fpa et on peut noter par exemple que
3,5 millions de salariés en 2011 sont
passés à lAFPA au titre d'un d'un titre
professionnel euh deuxè élément positif
dans les compétences et l'offre de
service de l'AFPA aujourd'hui c'est une
expertise reconnue en matière de
formation
industrielle trisème atout c'est un
savoir faire lui aussi reconnu et qui a
été évoqué à plusieurs reprises lors de
cette
audition en matière de formation des
populations les plus éloignées de
l'emploi en particulier des demandeurs
d'emploi quelqu soit le leur statut et
puis dernière dernier atout c'est le
maillage territorial de lAFPA qui est
dense qui est diversifié qui est une
charge en terme de fonctionnement mais
qui est aussi vu du côté des demandeurs
d'emploi un élément très important
puisque cela permet au demandeurs
d'emploi d'accéder à une
formation sans rencontrer trop de
difficultés de mobilité géographique
dont on sait qu'elles sont souvent des
obstacles à la formation des salariés et
des demandeurs d'emploi alors dans ce
contexte la politique de l'État
vis-à-vis de l'AFPA au fond elle repose
sur deux grands piliers il y a un
premier pilier qui est celui de la
politique du titre dont l'AFPA est un
acteur essentiel et qui justifie le
versement d'une subvention de l'État à
l'AFPA au titre d'un programme d'action
de service public le PASP pour 75
millions d'euros par an euh cette
politique du titre elle a été un petit
peu décrite tout à l'heure en fait je
soulligne que les titres professionnels
correspondent
à
une réalité qui permet à des personnes
euh sur la base de la reconnaissance du
geste professionnel et pas tellement de
connaissance théorique sur la base d'une
expérience concrète de voir reconnu leur
savoir-faire hein et je disais tout à
l'heure 3 millions de personnes par an
avec pour celles qui passent par lavep
un taux de réussite de 80 % ce qui est
tout à fait positif donc pour l'État la
politique du titre euh euh reste une
compétence importante qui justifie le
fait que l'fpa en soit un acteur central
deuxème élément important plus important
encore quantitativement que la politique
du titre c'est la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi c'est un atout de
l'AFPA pour l'État ça
donne l'assurance d'avoir un opérateur
qui est prêt à former les demandeurs
d'emploi lorsque cela est nécessaire
lorsque par exemple comme cela a été
évoqué tout à l'heure l'État décide
d'encourager la formation de demandeur
d'emploi comme ça a été le cas en 2013
avec l'opération
formation prioritaire de 30000 demandeur
d'emploi et comme cela sera le cas en
2014 avec l'opération formation
prioritaire de 100000 demandeurs
d'emploi l'AFPA obtient évidemment pas
la totalité de ces formations on l'a dit
la part de marché de l'ordre de 20 %
mais euh
elle reste néanmoins un acteur essentiel
de ces formations sur lequel l'État peut
compter pour suivre des impulsions comme
celles qui ont été données au cours de
l'année dernière et qui sera poursuivi
cette année alors trisème et dernier
point quelle est l'action de l'État
auprès de l'AFPA pour soutenir le plan
de redressement de l'association il y a
deux grands volets il y a un volet
financier puis un volet immobilier le
volet financier c'est une par
participation en fond propre auprès de
l'AFPA à hauteur de 200 millions qui qui
s'échelonneront entre 2013 et 2015 120
millions ayant déjà été versés
évidemment cette participation de l'État
s'accompagne d'un suivi particulier hein
suivi étroit par les différentes
administrations de l'État concerné
c'est-à-dire non seulement la dgfp mais
aussi le Siri la direction du budget de
la façon dont le plan de refondation de
l'AFPA est respecté par l'organisme et
en particulier de la façon dont
l'évolution du chiffre d'affaires
respecte les pures qui a été qui a été
défin puis de l'autre côté de la façon
dont les dépenses elles-mêmes se
réduisent au rythme qui a été prévu
alors ce que l'on constate pour 2013
comme ça a été souligné c'est que les
dépenses se sont réduites à peu près
comme ça avait été prévu même un tout
petit peu plus qu'en revanche le chiffre
d'affaires ça a été indiqué tout à
l'heure lui
est un petit peu inférieur à ce qui
avait été prévu de l'ordre de 35 million
d'euros il est très clair que pour
2014 les hypothèses de chiffre
d'affaires qui seront retenu en tous les
cas tels que les conçoit l'état devront
être en ligne avec ce qui est faisable
et que ce qui est attendu c'est que en
2014 lAFPA soit sur les objectifs de
chiffre d'affaires qui seront euh
défini alors deuxième volet c'est le
volet immobilier donc l'État soutient la
démarche de beau amphithéotique
administratif qui connaît un démarrage
difficile mais qui connaîtra au cours de
l'année 2014 un développement puisque
une douzaine de beau anfithéotiques
doivent être signés cette année la dgfp
comme l'a indiqué Monsieur estamp jouant
un rôle euh d'intermédiation he de
manière à ce que les contact se fasse de
la meilleure façon possible entre France
Domaine et lAFPA voilà les observations
que nous avions à faire madame la
Présidente sur le rapport de la
Cour très bien merci madame messieurs
pour cette présentation je vais donner
la parole à nos rapporteurs dans un
premier temps peut-être monsieur
jeaner ensuite j'ouvre tout de suite à
l'ensemble des sénateurs où je laisserai
peut-être répondre nos nos invités et
puis j'ouvrirai la discussion après
monsieur jeanou
bien merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais remercier d'abord madame la
Présidente de la 5e chambre pour sa
présentation très synthétique et
finalement très complète de la situation
de l'AFPA aujourd'hui vous avez rappeler
en particulier comment est né le le plan
de de refondation à la suite d'e d'une
perte financière observé à lAFPA de 90
millions d'euros et il faut rappeler que
ces 90 on représentait 10 % du chiffre
d'affaires et quand on examine
aujourd'hui le point d'arrivée du plan
de refondation tel que l'a décrit le
directeur général on observe aujourd'hui
que puisque je reprends pas les trois
mesures les trois familles de mesures
que vous avez rappelé qui constituent ce
plan de refondation on observe
aujourd'hui je parle sous votre contrôle
que effectivement il manque au chiffre
d'affaires escompté 30 millions d'euros
et vous nous dites et ça c'est une
perspective qui nous rassure que sur
2014 vous envisagez un excédent
d'exploitation de l'ordre de 1 à 2
millions d'euros alors comment est-ce
comptez-vous arriver à cet objectif et
en particulier effectivement pour y
parvenir il faudra sans doute vous en
conviendrez avec moi que le le le
rendez-vous avec le chiffre d'affaires
envisagé soit effectif et je voudrais
savoir sur ces 30 millions
d'euros qui sont aujourd'hui observés en
déficit est-ce qu'ils
résulte de difficultés de recrutement
des stagiaires c'est-à-dire est-ce que
les stagiaires n'ont pas été au
recrutement des formations en
particulier les 300 le plan 30000
ou ces difficultés
relèvent-ell du fait que vous n'ayez pas
obtenu les commandes de la part de
financeur les commandes attendues parce
que effectivement selon l'une ou l'autre
de ces hypothèses ça impliquera vous en
conviendrez avec moi un plan d'action
différent je voudrais deuxème question
vous interroger vous
l'avez bien décrit Monsieur le Directeur
général sur la question difficile je
crois que nous en convenons tous ici
d'ailleurs il y a un représentant de la
région Limousin parce que la la région
Limousin est assez emblématique de ce
que vous avez exposé il y a des
formations à caractère national qui
s'adressent à l'ensemble des demandeurs
d'emploi sur le territoire mais il se
trouve et vous l'avez rappelé que les
acheteurs aujourd'hui sont les régions
comment vous allez faire en sorte que la
région
Bourgogne dont le président est à mes
côté achète une formation de travaux
publics à aigleton en Limousin comment
les choses concrètement se passent-ell
parce que on est tous d'accord sur le
fait au fond ici que les formations du
Limousin sont d'intérêt national mais
comment concrètement cela se
réalise-t-il et on voit bien que c'est
dans euh c'est c'est dans les modalité
que que les choses échouent et puis euh
3isème question je voudrais revenir sur
la question du du patrimoine euh parce
que euh vous savez dans le projet de loi
que nous allons bientôt examiné ici euh
au Parlement et qui va être présenté
demain au Conseil des ministres il est
question de pouvoir céder aux régions du
patrimoine immobilier de de l'État
puisque cette possibilité est ouverte
euh par rapport au patrimoine mis
actuellement à disposition de l'AFPA et
qui et cette procédure si j'ai bien
compris doit être pouvoir autorisé par
la prochaine loi donc sur la formation
professionnelle est-ce que à votre point
de vue cette mesure répond telle aux
difficultés que que vous rencontrez
autour du patrimoine comment se
complète-elle avec ce que vous expliquez
sur les les BEA est-ce qu'on ne risque
pas au bout du compte une AFPA à deux
vitesses parce qu'on voit bien que cette
question du patrimoine elle est
lancinante et elle est prignante est-ce
qu'on ne risque pas une AFPA à deux
vitesse et
puis pourquoi pas une forme de
démantelllement de laafpa parce que le
patrimoine est un élément me semble-t-il
d'unité aussi de de de l'organisation
nationale et
puis je je je voudrais
aussi interroger un peu plus la la dgfp
sur une question qui qui me paraît j'ai
bien écouté ce qu'a dit le représentant
de la dgfp sur positionnement de l'AFPA
par rapport à l'État et une question qui
qui me paraît à moi pas complètement
clarifié c'est ce que vous entendez
aujourd'hui euh quand vous vous vous
vous définissez laafpa comme une
composante du service public de l'emploi
alors que madame la Présidente de la 5e
chambre a bien souligné que l'fpa était
aujourd'hui un organisme de formation
banaliser alors certes il y a la
politique du titre mais est-ce vraiment
suffisant pour continuer à affirmer que
l'AFPA est de
fait une composante du service public je
crois c que effectivement il y a une
attente de clarification de ce que
souhaite le le gouvernement en direction
de Lapa bon j'aurai d'autres questions
mais je voudrais laisser mes collègues
pouvoir s'exprimer avant peut-être de
pouvoir revenir à tel ou tel autre
aspect monsieur patria vous voulez
compléter en tant que rapporteur un ou
deux mots d'abord sur le constapis
peut-être les effets du cumul font que
entre le rapporteur ici et le président
de Région euh à confondre les gens mais
c'est une expérience d'abord moi moi je
suis un
peu surpris qu'on soit surpris parce que
le constat qu'on fait aujourd'hui il
était prévisible le jour où on a mis la
situation Lapa dans la situation où elle
est devenue on savait très bien que
lAFPA n'est pas un organisme de
formation
ordinaire d'une part de par ses
implantations de par son patrimoine
mais aussi de par la qualité et la
nature de ces
formations
Présidente c'est vrai que quand on
demande pas que j'ai visiter réion
bourgog d'accueillir par exemple des
stagiaires chez qui pe venir il vont
plus souventè dans Limousin chez moi
maisill les
stagiair qui viennent d'autres région
don une qualité de formation qui é
reconnu et dans le même temps de les
mettre dans la situation de marché
c'était évidemment les mettre en
situation concurrentielle difficile on
ne vend pas les mêmes formations donc
c'est la différence alors donc le
constat au bout de dire bah nous perdons
des paires de marché euh et les région
en face c'est vrai malgré ce qu'on a pu
dire ou écrire on bien compris que avec
des partenaires ou des opérateurs comme
lAFPA il y avait une différence dans la
qualité de l'offre cette différence
co un prix que elle était pas reconnue
par la
plart G qui étailients par qu' son après
tout on fait des formations les marchés
publics très bien March public on fait
que pour une formation d éalitaire la
notion de mieux
disant ce sont les régions mêm qui l'
fait apparître disant lorsque nous
allons passer le marché nous savons très
bien
que et mieux disante dans bien des
domaines que par la même de par la
qualité des installations la qualité de
l'accueil la qualité des formateurs
l'orientation qui était avec à côté
était de la donc jeallis dire on peut
pas être surpris du constat et je trouve
je le dis je directeur de de la de la GP
il y a une forme de cynisme non pas dans
vos propos dans l'attitude globale de
l'état de dire aujourd'hui bah on les a
un peu laissé en pleine nature mais
maintenant on s'aperçoit quand même
qu'ils ont des vraies
qualités des vraies qualités regardez ce
qu'ils font C assez exceptionnel la
politique du titre euh la qualité des
formations qui sont dispensées le niveau
voilà donc ce constat il était
prévisible aujourd'hui euh que la que
LAF pas est à se à se remettre en
question comme elle l'a fait il y a eu
de chemins de parcouru remise en
question sur le plan du nombre de
personnels de la réorganisation de la
j'allais dire de la reccentration des
reccentration des sites des sites vous
l'avez fait on peut le faire on a encore
de la démarche à faire ce que je
voudrais dire là en tant président de
région c'est que nous sommes prêts à
accompagner cette démarche nous sommes
pas prêts à prendre des charge
transférer aux région l'ensemble du
patrimoine pas c'est inconcevable
contenu du coûte surtout que on nous
demande aujourd'hui le président de
faire des économies de fonctionnement je
vous rappelle que tout ce qui concerne
les lycées comme les centres de
formation ça appartient au
fonctionnement des régions et non pas à
l'investissement donc ça veut dire que
dans notre marge bruit de futur regarder
à la loupe nons faire attention donc la
formule des beau des beau tel qu'
itthéotique administratif est une
formule qui a permis de de résoudre pour
partie 6 région mais nous entendons bien
avec les régions il participerai avec
vous ça veut dire qu'il y a je l' dis
ici deux efforts à faire et je crois
qu'ils sont en train de se mettre en
place le premier c'est la prise en
compte et la réorganisation ne lave pas
autour de ses missions qu'elle doit
concentrer en étant sûr qu'elle peut
effectivement personne ne le fait comme
eux des missionintérêt national chaque
région national le font mais que que
dans le même temps les régions sont
conscientes j'allais dire de la qualité
de l'opérateur qu'elles ont en face
d'elles je crois qu'elles en tiennent
compte dans leur marché je sais pas quel
est le niveau de dialogue que vous avez
avec les régions je parle pas de la
région bourgonne bienventinenement mais
globalement moi je voudrais vous
interroger sur aujourd'hui quelle est la
qualité du dialogue quel est le niveau
de dialogue que vous AZ avec les régions
est-il aujourd'hui non pas seulement
dans la compréhension mais dans la la
complémentarité pour arriver à parce que
moi je verrais très mal dans dans la
région que je préside
momentanément disparaître un outil tel
que laavp qui reste aujourd'hui un outil
d'élite avec lequel sur lequel nous
comptons avec lequel nous avons
confiance pour pouvoir poursuivre les
mission dans le cadre maintenant des
survis publi de la formation
professionnelle qui sont pour parti
régionalisé voilà madame la Présidente
les quelques remarques plutôt que les
questions que je voulais poser merci
peut-être quelques réponses à à ces
premières questions et remarques
absolument madame la Présidente merci
sur les 30 millions d'abord qui pour
prendre dans l'ordre qui nous manque on
a une vision extrêmement claire des
postes qui ont souffert il nous manque
100 millions sur une ligne
état qui est liée à des missions sur les
mutations économiques que nous faisons
auprès des directs donc les services
déconcentrés du ministère de l'Emploi
nous avions l'année précédente une
vention et en 2013 nous somes passés
sous appel d'offre euh et donc le temps
que l'administration se mette en place
les appels d'offres ne sont pas sortis
immédiatement et donc il y a certains
appels d'offres qui sont sortis au mois
de novembre de l'année ce qui veut dire
que indépendamment même si nous avions
eu 100 % des lots ce qui n'a pas été le
cas mais bon pour ça que il faut bon
c'est prévu comme ça mais euh nous avons
n'avons pas pu produire donc même avec
un taux de réussite important dans les
dans les appels d'offres dès lors queon
vous adjuge le lot on vous l'attribue au
mois de novembre voyz bien que vous
allez produire sur un mois et non pas
sur 12 ce qui fait qu'à la sortie il
nous manque 10 millions règne par ce
trou de système le deuxième trou de
système vient du FPSPP et euh des PEC
sur lequel il nous manque 15 millions
alors P c'est les péodes
euh oui euh préparatoire à l'emploi
préparation opérationnelle à l'emploi ça
y est des PO voilà euh préparation
opérationnelle à l'emploi euh
les PO c'est ça où un moment donné le
FPS changer les règles de cofinancement
avec les OPC et donc du jour au
lendemain on a arrêté les OPC ont arrêté
de nous financer les PEE c'est un trou
de système et elles ont été rétablies
ces règles de cofinancement en fin
d'année dans le casadre du plan 30000 ce
qui veut dire que là on a recommencé à
avoir des PEE mais pendant 8 mois on en
a pas eu parce que les règles de
cinancement ont changer et donc bon ben
voilà maintenant on peut plus les
financer et le dernier point c'est que
pô emploi nous a commandé un peu moins
de formation Lord de 5 millions à
l'inverse nous avons une compensation
entre le développement entreprise où
nous avions des objectifs ambitieux et
mais nous avons nous manque environ 10
12 millions et à l'inverse ce qu'on
pense avec les conseils régionaux et je
vais répondre avec la avec ce chiffre là
avec le la questionnement du président
patria c'est que par rapport au budget
que nous avions nous sommes au-dessus de
l'ordre de 15 millions sur un budget
global d'environ 400 vous voyez 400
millions les c'est le budget qu'on fait
avec les rég région on est à 15 millions
auudessus ce qu'on avait prévu ce qui
veut dire que nous avons avec le
président Barou rétabli je pense un
dialogue de qualité avec les régions et
dans toutes les régions je crois que le
discours que vous avez tenu est est
audible dans toutes les régions tout le
monde nous dit on voit bien ce que vous
apportez et on est heureux de voir qu'il
y a une nouvelle gouvernance une
nouvelle orientation une nouvelle écoute
de nos besoins et cetera et ça c'est
matérialisé dans dans le courant de
l'année où on a eu des lots
complémentaires on a eu bref et
finalement on a pu obtenir les commandes
voir même plus donc pour répondre à
votre question le dialogue avec les
régions aujourd'hui c'est
considérablement renoué et
qualitativement et quantitativement ce
qui ce qui nous met dans une certaine
schizophrénie permettez-moi de vous le
dire parce que comme l'a rappelé le
repentant la dgfp notre nos atouts c'est
le maillage territorial et donc nous
sommes partoutem du territoire n'importe
quel demandeur d'emploi un s'entve pas à
moins d'une heure de chez lui ou qu'il
soit sur le territoire c'est une un
atout fondamental et donc pour les
régions nous sommes un élément important
de l'aménagement du territoire régional
sauf que le ministère des Finances qui
n'a pas peut-être pas exactement le même
avis que mon voisin de droite me dit
mais attendez mais il faut réduire votre
nombre de centre parce que vous
comprenez bien que c'est un coup alors
oui effectivement c'est un coup mais de
l'autre côté c'est une demande des
régions et je perd du Chi d'affaires si
je ne vais pas à tel endroit ou tel
autre donc donc on voit bien les limites
de l'exercice par rapport à ça c'est que
nous devons c'est notre métier c'est en
ce sens que nous nous sentons dans le
service de l'emploi permettez-moi de
revenir sur ce thème-l très fortement
l'fpa est marqué au fer rouge par par
cette cette mission là et ce serait une
catastrophe que que qu'elle ne soit plus
considérée comme un membre prééminent du
service public de l'emploi et donc nous
avons cette difficulté aujourd'hui c'est
que nous devons ça mais on nous demande
aujourd'hui de rentabiliser et que donc
des facto ça passe par une optimisation
de notre mage territorial donc vous
voyez bien que là l'équilibre est
compliqué à
obtenir sur le le de la deuxième
question du sénateur jeanre sur le
financement de l'offre nationale
certaines régions la région limousan est
un très bon exemple on bien compris
qu'il avoir un centre national sur son
territoire impliqué des devoirs et que
donc la commande qui est passée par le
président du conseil régional excède
largement le besoin de la région
Limousin bien évidemment en tout état de
cause on voit bien que l'avenir passe
par des cofinancement avec peut-être un
peu de financement étatique ou du FPSPP
via les branches on voit bien qu'il y a
10 millions qui sont potentiell prévu
pour le FPP FPSPP le fond paritaire
sécation des parcours professionnels
là-dedans on voit bien que là-dedans il
faudrait trouver manière de pouvoir
alléger le fardau des régions qui comme
vous l'avez rappelé sont dans une
contrainte financière assez forte ce
n'est pas les seules sur la trème
question sur le patrimoine des régions
ce n pas une demande forte de l'AFPA que
le patrimoine soit réparti et ventilé
auprès de toutes les régions alors ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que ce
patrimoine il va falloir le
réhabiliter parler de l'obligation
handicapé au 1er janvier 2015 même si la
date va peut-être être repoussée mais
toutes les obligations lié au grenell de
l'environnement donc même si euh il en a
fait don aux régions il y a un coup
certain certaines régions ont commencé à
faire un travail là-dessus on s'est
rendu compte qu'il y avait on parlait
pas de queue de cerise donc ce qui veut
dire que on est là dans un moment où
entre la volonté et la réalité il y a
peut-être un écart euh certains agents
sont pas intéressés mais certains agents
le sont parce qu'elles sont en tension
sur un certain nombre d'équipement et on
voit bien qui peut y avoir une
mutualisation d'autres régions disent
vous savez j'ai quatre CFA qui sont
vides les lycées professionnels qui sont
vides je cours pas après le patrimoine
ne lave pas donc les situations sont
extrêmement contrastées sur l'ensemble
du territoire par rapport à ça alors
est-ce que ça va participer du du
démantellement de l'AFPA est-ce que la
régionalisation en tant que telle
participe du dépentement de l'AFPA nous
nous avons et nous revendiquons le
président barreau une AFPA nationale
parce que nous pensons qu'il y a des
besoins et l'offre l'offre à Rayonnement
nationale un premier exemple quand on
parle de programme 34 filières d'avenir
l'F pasa une mission la pasa une mission
làdedans quand je vous étais je dis
j'étais à Cherbourg la semaine dernière
la région est ravie que lAFPA est un
centre national et ravi de se dire que
un petit gars de Toulouse quand il
voudra se former sur les EMR il viendra
à Cherbourg et donc la région est prête
à investir là-dedans parce qu'elle voit
bien l'intérêt et le rayonnement qu'elle
peut en obtenir et donc après est-ce que
le centre de cherrebourg va appartenir à
la région ou pas est-ce qu'il va
appartenir à la ville de Cherbourg qui
sait où à la communauté d'agloot à la
limite est- bien grave c'est pas très
grave ce qui ce qui est ce qui est
important c'est de bien voir ce que fait
la région de voir ce que peut apporter
LAFA et lAFPA est au milieu de cette
offre de proximité et de cette offre à
vocation nationale qui s'inscrit dans la
vision de notre politique industrielle
donc le monde tout le monde peut le
comprendre et la gestion quadripartide
qui est la nôtre les gens s'entendent
bien comprennent bien donc je pense que
il y a une volonté s'il y a une volonté
qui est la notre aujourd'hui de
préservver staff pas naational qui est
un atout
euh je je j'insiste sur cette affaire-là
euh quand on parle de on forme des
demandeurs d'emploi mais on travaille
aussi avec les entreprises quand vous
passez un contrat avec un groupe comme
la poost ou Carrefour qui dit voilà je
vous un contrat on va former je sais pas
moi des assistants de paye dans 16
régions et bien nous notre enjeu c'est
d'arriver à donner dans 16 régions la
même formation la même qualité de
formation le même nombre d'heur le même
parcours et donc ça c'est un atout
considérable qui justifie une AFPA
nationale et nous pensons que pour les
présidents de région cet équilibre là
est bien compris qui ne cherche pas
forcément le remettre en
question voilà donc par rapport aux
questions qui m'était posé et donc j'ai
rebouclé la
première service public peut-être
monsieur strel si vous voulez compléter
bien sûr madame la Présidente alors
effectivement concernant le le service
public de l'emploi d'abord c'est une
réalité juridique l'appartenance de
l'AFA au service public de l'emploi
résulte de l'article L 531 de du Code du
travail bon et la justification de
l'inscription de l'AFPA au sein du
service public de l'emploi repose
évidemment sur la politique du titre et
l'action de l'AFA en matière de
certification et d'ingénierie du titre
professionnel cela étant même si laafpa
est aujourd'hui dans un statut banalisé
dans ses actions de formation
professionnel vu du ministère du Travail
et de l'Emploi ça reste néanmoins un
acteur un petit peu particulier pour des
raisons qui ont été rappelés ici pour
son maillage territorial d'abord pour sa
capacité à mener des euh mission
d'intérêt national alors c'est
évidemment pas le seul formateur qui est
capable de le faire mais c'est l'un des
principaux formateurs qui soit capable
de le faire et à cet égard dans l'annexe
financière que l'État a conclu avec le
FPSPP pour l'année 2014 il y a eu
effectivement une ligne d'une dizaine de
millions d'euros prévu pour le
financement de formation à caractère
national dont laafpa ne sera évidemment
pas le seul bénéficiaire mais dont on
espère que l'AFPA pourra
euh valablement répondre aux offres qui
en résulteront et puis enfin l'AFPA
n'est pas un formateur tout à fait comme
les autres dans la mesure où il est l'un
des rares qui soit capable d'intégrer
des actions de formation avec un
hébergement dont j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure à quel point pour les demandeurs
d'emploi c'était un élément important
puisque ça permet de palier un certain
nombre de difficultés en matière de
mobilité géographique et d'accessibilité
des formation alors je juste répondre à
à quelques autres points qui ont été
évoqués sur la position de l'État par
rapport à l'fpa j'espère queelle elle
n'est pas elle n'est pas cynique en tous
les cas l'État fait la preuve de son
engagement auprès de l'AFPA en
consentant dans des temps budgétaire
particulièrement difficile un
investissement qui est considérable
puisque il s'élève comme je l'ai indiqué
tout à l'heure à 200 millions d'euros
sur sur 3 ans donc euh l'État s'engage
pleinement au côté de l'affpa ce qui
manifeste aussi sa confiance dans la
capacité de l'AFPA à mener à bien son
plan de refondation et puis ensuite pour
ce qui est du patrimoine de de de de
l'AFPA de la possibilité d'une
dévolution de ce patrimoine aux régions
tel que le prévoit le projet de loi qui
sera présenté au Conseil des ministres
demain matin
euh je je pense que la solution aux
questions immobilières que soulève
l'avpa ne pourra en aucun cas être une
solution unique je crois que le temps où
on pensait que un modèle unique pourrait
être de donneré au problème immobilier
de lAFPA et révolu et qu'aujourd'hui on
s'engage vers du cas par cas alors dans
un certain nombre de cas on fera des
beaux hitthéotiques administratif et
puis dans un certain nombre d'autres cas
il pourrait y avoir pour les régions qui
sont intéressées transfert du patrimoine
des de l'immobilier de l'AFPA de l'État
vers les régions encore une fois c'est
sans doute un processus qui prendra du
temps mais c'est un processus qui ne
pourra se faire qu'au plus proche du
territoire et en fonction des besoins
qui seront exprimés par les acteurs
locaux merci messieur pour ces premières
réponses il est vrai que dans ces
questions de la Cour des comptes n'a pas
été sollicité directement donc je vais
peut-être ouvrir le débat à mes
collègues j'avais Madame Christiane de
moness inscrite
et pour le moment personne d'autre
madame de moness vous avez la
parole
merci merci madame la Présidente de la
5e chambre de la Cour des comptes pour
pour ce rapport moi j'avais
effectivement un certain nombre de
questions il y en a qui ont déjà été
posé par par mes collègues alors je vais
les je vais les enlever mais dans le
rapport pour revenir sur le le rapport
en tout cas le les les le document que
nous avons et de manière de manière pour
vous poser des manières de manière un
peu précise des des questions vous dites
dans ce rapport madame la Présidente que
la pas sans doute été pénalisé par le
départ des du près d'un millier de
psychos de l'AFPA dans le processus
d'orientation et du coup d'affectation
des stagiaires euh pour autant les
psychos ils sont partis à emploi puisque
tout ça s'est fait dans le cadre de la
loi de portant création de Pôle Emploi
donc les psychos ils existe toujours
donc comment on
explique que les psychos parce qu'ils ne
sont plus à la pas et parce que les
formations de l'AFPA sont bien comment
on explique qu'il n'orient plus les
demandurs d'emploi vers vers l'AFPA et
je j'étends ma question comment sur les
territoires quels sont les rapports de
l'AFPA des AFPA des centres AFPA sur les
territoires avec les prescripteurs de
formation pour les demandur d'emploi
parce que il y a un dispositif alors
qu'on peut analyser c'est pas le l'enjeu
de la réunion de cet après-midi mais sur
les territoires et en particulier à
l'initiative des régions il y a des
dispositifs qui existent et le sentiment
que j'ai c'est que lAFPA se situe pas
forcément mais sans doute est- lié à son
histoire se situe pas forcément de
manière cohérente par rapport justement
à cette organisation des territoires et
par rapport au au prescripteurs et en
particulier les structures de
l'information et de l'orientation donc
j'ai j'avais une une question là-dessus
au au directeur de l'AFPA une deuxième
question mais qui a été largement
abordée par par Claude janreau sur les
formations av voocation nationales on a
tous l'exemple de agleton avec le grand
centre des formations du bâtiment qui
effectivement la région Mousin qui en
plus et ça n'a rien de péjoratif est une
petite région ne peut pas assumer solld
donc effectivement dans la discussion
avec l'État est-ce qu'on peut imaginer
euh qu'il y ait au niveau national un
certain nombre de formations à vocation
nationale et donc de centre de formation
vous avez évoqué cherbour monsieur le
directeur dans lesquels l'État au lieu
de dans le processus de décentralisation
confié aux régions et en accord avec ell
ces formations-l pourraiit reprendre la
main sur des formations à à vocation
nationale donc la question s'adresse
aussi à Monsieur le Directeur adjoint de
la DGEFP 3è question euh de nature un
peu différente les Organismes de
Formation elfp est un organisme de
formation se situe à la fois dans un
dans un processus de formation des
demandeurs d'emploi hein plutôt avec des
financements publics mais aussi dans un
processus de formation des salariés en
entreprise et en particulier des dans le
cadre des plans de formation dans
l'entreprise donc est-ce que la FAA a
engagé des démarches auprès de des
entreprises en particulier des OPCA hein
des des branches professionnelles pour
être à la fois sur le champ des
demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi sur le
champ des salariés je le dis parce qu'il
me semble pour suivre un peu ces
questionsl il me semble qu'il y a un
vrai intérêt pour les organismes de
formation et en particulier pour l'AFPA
à être à la fois répondor de formation
sur les demandeurs d'emploi mais aussi
sur les salariés je crois qu'il y a des
a des des des choses qui peuvent évoluer
dans ce sens et puis ma dernière
question peut-être en guise de
conclusion c'est vraiment j'ai été
vice-présidente d'une région qui est la
région ronalpe au moment justement de la
décentralisation et et de de de la
décentralisation de la régionalisation
des centres de l'AFA et la question que
je me pose c'est la question
effectivement du position ement de lAFPA
par rapport sur le territoire par
rapport aux autres organismes de
formation euh je pense c'est dit par le
rapport de de la Cour des comptes je
pense que
l'fpa mais c'est facile de le dire après
coup hein l'fpa a pas forcément bien
négocier cette question de la cette
décentralisation de de la formation et
je crois qu'on peut le dire comme ça il
est allé plutôt arculon quoi je et et
donc du coup elle a un peu de retard et
ça ne remet pas en cause la qualité des
formations mais justement du coup cette
qualité des formations elle passe un peu
derrière d'autres choses et j'ai un peu
l'impression à un moment mais les
présidents de région en particulier
président de région qui qui est là
François patria me démentira s'il pense
je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'offre de
formation au au niveau régional elle
doit faire partie d'un réseau je veux
dire l'enjeu c'est moins la concurrence
que la complémentarité et et je trouve
ENF il me semble mais vous allez
répondre à ma question que laa n'a pas
bien encore trouvé sa place dans ce
positionnement
territorial voilà c'est j'auraai
d'autres questions mais je vais
m'arrêter là madame la Présidente parce
que j'en ai déjà suffisamment
pé merci Madame du moness pas d'autre
demande de parole donc je vous redonne
la parole
messieur vous voulez monsieur oui je je
veux bien je veux bien alors je prendre
répondre par la dernière question enfin
le dernier point que vous soulevez la
réponse est est oui madame la sénatrice
de manière évidente LAFA a toujours cru
à un moment donné peut-être que il y
aurait un retour en arrière et
effectivement n'a pas abordé
euh les les les les problématiques qui
lui étaient posé de la manière la plus
efficace c'est incontestable pour
prendre le cas de la région ronalp
région nous nous sommes fait laminer à
l'occasion de l'appel d'offre qui une
région école chez
nous mais je pense que en P cette année
et je pense qu'on sera meilleur euh mais
ce qui montre bien pourquoi on a des
difficultés c'est que nous avons 12
centres en ronalpe nous avons
aujourd'hui 34 implantation parce qu'il
y a une démarche en rondalp qui vient de
27 territoires une démarche très
territorialisée et nous par rapport à ça
on a répondu à moment donné écoutez nous
avons une offre en catalogue nous on
fait comme ça depuis depuis 150 ans donc
écoutez voilà et donc on nous a expliqué
que c'était plus comme ça que ça se
passait donc mais ça je dirais ce n'est
pas la régionalisation qui nous a fait
mal c'est la mise en concurrence qui
nous a fait mal voyez quand on a quand
avec l'État on est mis en appel d'offre
si on n'est pas bon on n pas le lot non
plus donc les région n ont pas été
hostiles mais à un moment donné il
fallait qu'on écoute précisément le
besoin qui qui était remonté et signifi
à lavep qu'on a peut-être pas su faire
il y a quelques années mais qu'on essaie
de faire aujourd'hui croyez-moi euh pour
de manière pour être effectivement dans
les services publics régionaux et de
délivrer ce qu'on attend de nous euh
sur la distinction entre demandeur
d'emploi est actif nous pensons que
cette distinction est totalement
artificielle un demandeur d'emploi est
un actif demain un actif aujourd'hui est
un demandeur d'emploi de demain pour
vous donner des chiffres entreprises
parce qu'il y a aussi le CF aussi donc
le marché entreprise il y a aussi les
CSP ça fait 180 millions de chiffre
d'affaires à
lAFPA pour sur 800 millions de budget
pour faire ça pour les idées claires
donc ce qui veut dire c'est pas
dérisoire ce n'est pas dérisoire et dans
le futur nous pensons que nous allons
nous développer là-dessus je j'en veux
pour preuve si on regarde l'histoire de
laafpa euh lAFPA s'est positionné sur
les demandeurs d'emploi au tournant des
années 80 mais à l'origine immédiate
après gu travaill pour les entreprises
donc ce sujet n'est pas tabou même si
effectivement aujourd'hui notre
évolution nous positionne sur la
demandeur l'emploi donc HC PF et cetera
nous avons d'excellentes relations
là-dedans et nous travaillons avec ces
gens-là alors
euh sur sur le départ des psychos
effectivement moi je pense c'est ça qui
a fait le plus de mal voyez dans la
catégorie qu'est-ce qui a fait le plus
de mal la mise en concurrence devient 2è
rang dans mon analyse premier rang
estant le départ des des 1000 psychos
900 vers pôul emploi
euh pourquoi parce que nous avions là
alors effectivement comme l'a rappelé le
Conseil de la concurrence c'était
peut-être une position un peu excessive
et nous avions une capacité à pouvoir
remplir nos stages avec nos psychos qui
aiguillaient euh principalement les gens
va les stages de lavepa euh c'est ça la
réalité et donc aujourd'hui la relation
avec poemploi même si elle est bonne et
il y a aucun souci avec pour l'emploi on
se connaît très bien avec au niveau
local mais c'est très compliqué parce
que Pôle Emploi les gens le conseiller
de Pôle emploi doit avoir en visibilité
immédiate le stage la programmation de
la pas mais pas que de la pas et donc
vous voyez que la programmation et
l'affectation la prescription est
beaucoup plus complexe si on considère
en plus qu'il y a plusieurs
outils en région ronalp c'est la région
à son outil qui s'appelle prosperère
pour l'emplo son til s'appelle cerise il
y a Vals donc chaque fois il faut queil
y ait les interconnexions parfois il y
en a pas donc on perd l'information et
ce qui veut dire que qu' on perd on a
des places on a des gens qui ne savent
pas P l'emploi ne sait pas que à tel
endroit on aurait besoin on aurait des
places de libre et donc aujourd'hui on a
une inefficience à cause de ces outils
informatiques différents et à cause
cette multiplicité d'intervenants
euh sur les formations national est-ce
que toi de reprendre la main sur les
formations nationales je pense
qu'effectivement il y a un certain
nombre de formations qui doivent être
identifié et comme le rappeler le le
président por également vousmême madame
la région Limousin est une petite région
et on peut pas lui demander et c'est
pareil pour toutes les régions alors il
faut trouver un nombre assez réduit il
faut bien les identifier il faut bien
voir les moyens que l'on donne euh il y
a dans la loi de finances pour 2014 un
programme s'appelle le p412 qui est dans
l'esprit du du PIA du plan
d'investissement d'avenir qui permet de
financer des projets où justement on
s'inscrit dans ces investissements
d'avenir donc on voit bien la proximité
qu'il peut avoir avec la politique
industrielle du pays dans lequel si on
arrive à constituer unre organisme de
formation entreprise collectivité l'État
peut mettre de l'argent sur la table
pour pouvoir
investir à bon niveau parce que ce fond
est doté d'environ 150 millions sont
faire de ma part
aujourd'hui monsieur strassel sur la
question relative au financement des
formations à caractère national outre ce
qui vient d'être mentionné par par
Monsieur estamp mais sur le formation
sur le financement des formations
elles-même je pense que
euh
le rôle de l'État doit exister pour ce
financement mais qui doit plus passer
par l'incitation aux différents acteurs
de niveau national à se coordonner pour
financer que de financer lui-même hein
et donc l'exemple que je cité tout à
l'heure qui est celui de l'annexe
financière du FPSPP qui prévoit des
financements pour les formations à
caractère national euh mais aussi la
mobilisation dans le cadre du Plan
100000 formation demandeur d'emploi de
pôul emploi sont des actions qui sont à
l'initiative ou encouragé par l'État
mais qui ne suppose pas nécessairement
un financement direct de la part de
l'État très bien monsieur le rapporteur
Claude janre souhaitait compléter par
une dernière question oui j'avais une
dernière question il y a je crois encore
aujourd'hui un rêve enfoui au cœur des
syndicalistes de l'AFPA tout syndicat
confondu c'est de se dire qu'il y a des
des solutions pour contrer les règles de
la concurrence c'est ce
fameux
SG et vous savez que le projet de loi
que nous allons bientôt examiner ici
prévoit un futur service d'intérêt
économique général de la formation pour
les personnes qui rencontrent des
difficultés particulières d'insertion et
qui devrait pouvoir au niveau niveau
régional précisément être
consacré comment
envisagez-vous la participation ou
l'implication de lAFPA par rapport à ce
dispositif alors à l'heure où nous
parlons le seg fonctionne pleinement
dans six régions donc nous sommes déjà
confrontés à ce service intérêt
économique général avec l'attribution de
mandatement de droit particulier dans la
droit fil de la jurisprudence de la CJCE
Almar
ce dispositif a des avantages
c'està-dire qu'il permet de réellement
faire de fédérer des opérateurs et de
créer un service public régional de
fédérer des partenariats donc ça c'est
une de ses vertus un de ses principaux
défauts est qu'il est d'une complexité
sans nom et que pour ce qu'on appelle la
juste compensation c'està-dire quels
sont les les les coûts engagés comment
les
compenser c'est très compliqué et donc
dans six régions nous avons six
procédures différentes
avec des débats sans fin chez nous des
armées
d'administratifs dans la collectivité
des armées d'administratif et forcément
des cabinets qui viennent auditer tout
ça et donc au bout d'un moment on se dit
est-ce que là on n'est pas en train de
tuer une bonne idée on va dire donc donc
c'est un peu ça notre position nous nous
espérons et nous aimerions estce que
c'est prend la forme d'un décret estce
que c'est pour la forme on sait pas
encore qu'il y ait une méthodologie un
guide qui puisse de manière
univoque et
sans difficulté d'interprétation
localement puisse dire très clairement
qu'est-ce qu'on prend en charge à quel
niveau on le prend de manière à
réellement simplifier la tâche de tout
le monde et pouvoir visualiser les
choses de manière la plus sereine
possible donc nous la lavep nous n
sommes pas
hos nous pensons que il y a plusieurs
modalités la DSP le seg le le marché la
plus belle chose du monde c'est quand
vous gagnez marché public voyez ça c'est
bien vous voyez vous l'avez gagné
c'estoue euh la pire c'est quand vous le
perdez vous voyez voilà donc tout est
résumé là- dedans et que donc nous on
préfère quand on travaille et que ce
soit prèslune ou l'autre des modalités
de commande publique il faut que tout
les unes les autres qu'elles soient
pacifié c'estàd que sur les marchés
publics on soit pas avec des prix qui
soient tirés trop vers le bas que les si
soi pas trop complexes enfin bref
voilà Monsieur de cessar finalement une
question oui madame la
jeen prie écoutant Monsieur le Directeur
tout à l'heure il nous a parlé de trou
pour le bque à gagner là sur l'née les
30 millions vous nous avez parlé d'un
trou je ne me rappelle plus le mot que
vous avez
employé un trou système voilà donc le
temps que je comprenne le
nom c'est pour ça que je formule ma
question que maintenant madame la
Présidente alors le trou système j'ai
cru comprendre que vous attendiez des
commandes et que comme elle venait pas
il y a un grand trou système bon
et ça veut dire que vous avez gardé tout
le personnel pendant la période où vous
attendiez
le le le le contrat donc là qui est-ce
qui est
responsable vous
ou celui qui n'a pas fait à temps la
commande d'après
vous je vais vous répondresieur je crois
je connais un peu la la réponse avant la
somme importante parce que si c'était je
sais pas 10000 € on pourrait dire bon
mais là c'est c'est des sommes quand
même considérables quoi dans le monde de
la formation professionnelle euh la
plupart des opérateurs c'est 10 % de CDI
90 % de CDD à lAFPA c'est 90 % de CDI et
10 % de CDD ce qui veut dire qu'on
investit sur nos formateurs on les forme
on les fait évoluer on les recrute à un
niveau important et donc c'est une
matière matière première rare et de
première qualité donc il n'est pas dans
l'idée de lAFPA dans la politique de
l'AFPA de se comporter alors je n'ai
aucun mépris hein mais on n'est pas du
tout dans la même finalité donc nous
nous prétendons dispenser de la
formation de qualité et donc des facto
et bien quand on formateurs qui sont pas
occupés et bien c'est tant pis pour nous
c'est un coût alors on essaie par la
mobilité interne de pouvoir les adapter
les faire faire d'autres missions et
cetera mais c'est une difficulté et
effectivement pour reprendre votre
expression notre système c'est
exactement ça qui s'est passé où on nous
dit mais attendez alors on est en 2012
on dit l'année prochaine attention c'est
plus la subvention c'est les appels
d'offres ils vont arriver là ils
arrivent c'est imminent et puis février
on voit et puis mars non mais là ça
arrive non mais là c'est bloqué non ça
va arriver c'est imminent c'est
extrêmement difficile de pouvoir se
projeter par rapport à ça et donc donc
effectivement on a subi le coup comme on
dit dans le
sport merci Monsieur d'avoir
répondu ceci mais la question qui est
posée c'est comment si vous êtes si vous
avez un trou système régulièrement puis
que vous êtes en train de me dire et
vous avez raison certainement d'un
certain point de vue que vous allez
conserver 90 % de CDI et que vous
souhaitez bien les former les garder
longtemps et que vous êtes par rapport
aux appels d'offre affaiblis puisque
l'appel d'offre peut tomber au mois de
janvier mais peut tomber au mois d'avril
ou il peut tomber au mois de juin donc
si vous avez une politique et vous avez
raison
de de qualité des des formateurs que
vous voulez maintenir comment
voulez-vous ne pas avoir de trous
système avec les les aléas justement des
régions des difficultés financière ou
politique d'un directeur qui peut
changer d'orientation dans une région
donc là est posé quand même la question
de avec un système que vous voulez de
qualité comment vous pouvez et des trous
systm qui vont arriver comment vous
pouvez être compétitif s'il n'y a pas de
la part de l'État ou de la région la
prise en compte de de ce considérant de
ce paramètre je crois que l'explication
était intéressante écoutez je n'ai pas
d'autres inscrit pas d'autres demandes
je vous
remercie messieur madame pour votre
présentation et pour la qualité de vos
réponsse je souhaite avec mes collègues
que l'AFPA puisse continuer à vivre
encore longtemps et à faire partie des
opérateurs des
opérateurs du système du service public
en tout cas moi c'est comme ça que je
l'entends service public de
formation pour pour du service public de
l'emploi voilà et dans ce prochain texte
qui nous arrive prochainement je pense
que nous aurons encore à débattre et de
l'AFPA et de la formation professionnel
dans sa
globalité je vous propose donc mes chers
collègues que la Commission autorise la
publication donc de l'enquête de la Cour
des comptes à sortie de nos débats de
cet après-midi sous la forme d'un
rapport d'information déposé par notre
collègue Claude janre ce qui permettra
et bien à ce que ces travaux de la cour
puissent être publi ce qui est quand
même toujours plus intéressant et pour
nous en tant que parlementaire mais je
pense également pour les auteurs de ces
de ces travaux toujours intéressant de
pouvoir être publié donc mes chers
collègues je vous propose la publication
de ce rapport et de nos débats merci
puisqu'il n'y a pas d'opposition c'est
acté merci à vous pour cette échange
voilà pour cette audition consacrée aux
conclusions de l'enquête que la Cour des
comptes a mené sur la mauvaise gestion
de l'fpa l'association de Formation
Professionnelle des Adultes vous pouvez
bien sûr toujours voir et revoir toutes
les auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire et bien cet
après-midi pour une audition cons ré à
l'échotax très bonne journée sur la
chaînes
parlementaires cette maison qui est en
face ce sera la maison des
parisien il 13 ans Bertrand de laané
mettait fin à des années de règne de la
droite à Paris avec un nouveau style et
un nouveau mot d'ordre annieidalgo sa
première adjointe à l'époque sur la
photo héritelle de son style et avec
quel succès NKM la challengeuse très
proche de Nicolas Sarkozi va-t-elle
réussir à imposer le sien atypique en
politique et avec quels arguments
au-delà des programmes l'une et l'autre
tent-elle de conquérir le cœur des
Parisiens cette semaine nous
déshabillons en tout bien tout honneur
deux femmes que tout
oppose
samedi à 23h45 sur public
sénna